from dragon flame foreshadowing to
easter eggs revealing how fan favorite
fairies technet and flora will appear
fate the wink saga has a stack of
secrets hidden in every episode
yupikai movie lovers i'm jan and today
i'm uncovering all the magical details
you might have missed in the first
season of netflix's live action
adaptation of winx club including the
secret twist that ms dowling's face in
the finale may not be what it seems
we will of course be talking spoilers so
take care
although the new series initially
downplays fans expectations of getting
to see the wings with fairy wings
i'm just kind of bummed i didn't see a
single pair of wings well we had wings
in the past
as we've evolved transformation magic
has been lost the red buster fly on the
lamp that bloom brings with her to
althea is a clever bit of foreshadowing
to her big transformation in the finale
when she sprouts wings as she unleashes
the power of the dragonflame inside her
and that scene pays homage to elements
of bloom's original winx club
transformation
albeit with some notable differences the
fire that licks around her as she goes
full fairy is similar to the animation
although in winx club the fire wrapping
around bloom is accompanied by a costume
change
if you're disappointed by the netflix
show's lack of costume change
remember that bloom has only just
discovered the dragon flame and as her
powers grow in the future her
transformations may well become bigger
and better
and hopefully the other wink suite
members will also get wings too
like in the animated show by the way in
the original winx club the dragon flame
also gave
bloom healing abilities including the
time she was able to save skye
after a fatal attack and it appears that
in fate bloom has also acquired a
similar ability when she heals a cut on
skye's face
just by touching it another big moment
from the final episode
comes when rosalind abruptly kills
pharah with her magic by snapping her
neck
this was an unexpected and shocking
moment but also somewhat
underwhelming way for a powerful fairy
like ms dowling to exit the show
if you're a fara fan though you can take
solace in the subtle hint you might have
missed in the scene that suggests the
former headmistress may still be alive
notice how pharah's eyes light up just
before rosalind attacks her suggesting
she may be drawing on her own magic to
protect herself
against a likely attack from her nemesis
pharah's dead body may simply be an
illusion she's cast to full rosalind
like many of the other illusions we've
seen fairies cast in the show
and if you're at all skeptical then just
remember that skye's father andreas was
brought back from the dead despite the
seemingly lethal blow that silver landed
on him
and let's not forget that handy healing
power that bloom has either
the casting of terra and musa has been
problematic given how it raised both
latin and
asian representation in the new series
making this show's main cast less
diverse than the original naughties
animation
there is however a tease to a potential
resolution for fans disappointed that
lack of flora in the series when tara
reveals some more details about her
family to musa i've got this cousin
called flora my mom's called rose the
flora name drop
hopefully means that the og winx club
nature fairy who was modeled on jennifer
lopez will be introduced in a future
season
another missing founding fairy from the
animated series is techne the fairy of
technology
however there's a clue in the first
season that might have revealed her or
somebody closely related to her
in the third episode when bloom is
studying some of the alfia yearbooks the
camera deliberately goes in close on one
of the pages
lingering on it for several seconds
interestingly one of the names on the
page
devon walla is described as a science
fair winner
it looks like this description refers to
this former alumna of alfia here
who also appears in the center of this
group photo and who bloom commented was
a farrah fawcett look alike when she saw
her in a school photo on one of the
walls
the show seems to be calling attention
to this character and the fact that she
was particularly skilled at science
could imply that this is techner or if
not tekna herself
and somebody related to her for example
her mother of course it's possible that
this is just a tease to a brand new
original character that will be
introduced later on but either way it
seems likely she will have some
significance in a future
storyline also mentioned on the page is
somebody called sparta west red and if
you have any theories about techno or
either of these two characters comment
below
when bloom meets rosalind for the first
time the show seems to imply that the
voices bloom has been hearing calling to
her have been rosalinds all along
hello however if you go back and listen
to the ghostly voices that bloom
originally heard calling to her they
sound quite different to roslyn's voice
these may actually be a hint and tease
to daphne who was a type of spirit
guardian and sister to bloom in winx
club
similar to the mysterious voice calling
to bloom in the new show
daphne's ghost also called to bloom and
winks club to come and find her
i'm all around you blue i'm within you
bloom
i'll show you whoa
daphne daphne was also once a guardian
of the dragon flame and so if she
appears in the show
she'll likely have a part to play in
helping bloom learn about that power
althea's resident bad girl beatrix may
be an air fairy
however her name is a reference to the
villainous trick sisters from winx club
who were witches
beatrix also says that she's from astor
del which was apparently a village of
blood witches
suggesting it's possible that beatrix
will actually turn out to be a witch in
the show
rather than a fairy and although beatrix
appears to combine
various attributes of the three og
tricks i see darcy and stormi it
wouldn't surprise me if she discovers
she has a couple of villainous sisters
or relations in a future season
and if you were ever in any doubt that
bad boy riven would end up
joining beatrix on the dark side the
infamous book on his desk is a dead
giveaway
the overall theme of the prince by
machiavelli that it's justifiable to act
in an immoral way in order to achieve
political goals
also points to some of the themes in the
first season such as rosalind lying
about evacuating astadel
so she could destroy the blood witches
living there as well as the burned ones
another little detail about riven you
might have missed comes in the final
episode when he meets rosalind for the
first time
notice how both his and dale's eyes
light up as she enters the room which
could suggest that they have some latent
magical abilities
or the way that roslyn's eyes glowed at
the same time could imply that she's
cast a spell on them to pull them over
to her side as she takes control over
the school
there's a hint that we could see some of
the more interesting powers aisha had in
the animated series in fate
for clues let's take a look at the scene
where pharah is explaining to aisha
about her water-based powers
a mass of water is persistent and
reliable a drop of water
is unpredictable vague amorphous can you
isolate it can you maintain
that which fights form farah's
description of water as amorphous
could be a reference to morphix the name
of aisha's power source in winx club and
a magical malleable substance which the
fairy can create by rearranging water
molecules
i'm not sure whether the fate
showrunners will go there but there are
some really cool things like aisha's
morphic surfboard which could be awesome
to see in live action
more by the way there's also a hint in
fate that aisha might be a princess like
she is in winx club when stella tells
bloom to ask aisha what it means to lose
a crown jewel now that might not mean
much to a first welder so feel free to
ask your suite mate how big of a
screw-up that is
almost as big as giving it to her in the
first place another change from winx
club is musa being a mind fairy rather
than a fairy of music
there are however a few references in
the new series to her musical background
in the animation
from the dj poster on the wall by her
bed to how she listens to music on her
headphones whenever she wants to drown
out reading other people's emotions
to the fact that she tells riven she was
once a dancer i wouldn't expect a mind
fairy to have such good moves
i used to be a dancer fashion was a huge
part of winx club and fans of that
aspect of the og
show would likely be disappointed with
the costuming on fate
there is perhaps a small nod to winx
club fashion however when bloom is
surprised at how often stellar changes
their clothes each day
so casual thing that you're changing for
people have seen me in this outfit
already
they'll expect something different
people expect you to wear
multiple outfits a day and there's
another neat little homage to the og
series when bloom reveals that she was
born in 2004
a reference to how winx club first
premiered on italian tv in that year
and in case you didn't know abigail
cohen who plays bloom also starred in
netflix's chilling adventures of sabrina
as one of the three weird sisters and if
you're a fan of that show
check out my video with all the best
easter eggs and things you missed in the
final season of sabrina
tap here to watch that or follow the
link in the video description
so what did you think of fate the winx
saga and how it changed from the
animated series
and do you have any theories on what
you'd like to see in season two
leave all your thoughts and comments
down below and if you enjoyed this then
a thumbs up is hugely appreciated
tap left for my next netflix video
including a full breakdown of the
sabrina series finale and a potential
part 5 or tap right for something else
you're sure to like
thanks for watching and see you next
time yupikai movie lovers